yo yo what's your boy young blue check
me out on the bootleg care podcast we're
gonna go in make sure you tune in let's
get it
yo it's the bootleg cab show blackhead
podcast got my brother in here man
so young blue what to do welcome
i feel like the last time we did an
interview you
uh were getting ready to put your ep out
and this was right before i feel like
life changed for you
yeah yeah and uh you got this drake
feature
which i know you've talked about a
million [ __ ] times at this point but
you and i haven't seen each other since
then like
yeah how much has that feature because
that record was number one at radio
i mean yeah it's one of those songs that
like as a radio guy like i'm like tired
of which is a good thing
yeah because it's played out you know
that means you can't play too much how'd
that record change your life bro
uh just i mean uh
that's a lot of ways i mean you know i
was uh
unlocked on lockdown he came out like
during quarantine so i really
didn't really get the uh experience like
every
everything for real but i think it just
kind of made me more uh
richer you know what i'm saying probably
beat by it
that's probably like you know that helps
the biggest thing
yeah you've been still doing shows
though um bro
yeah i've still been doing shows like i
saw you was in my i saw you was in tempe
you killed the phoenix that [ __ ] looked
crazy
well i think i'm just starting about to
not do as many shows as i was doing
but are you uh are you going to be doing
like the solo headlining tour
or are you that's what i'm doing at the
end of august so that's going to be like
the heart of you is that going to be
like your first like real hard tickets i
know you do spot dates you know run
around get the bag and all that [ __ ] but
like this is like going to be the first
real tour yeah my first one
yeah yeah that's exciting man that's got
to be fun
yeah yeah um
how's the uh entrepreneurial ventures
going i think the last time we talked
we were talking about how you ran out
your tour bus yeah i realized man i
ain't gonna lie i really
been uh too much on my uh
like my other adventures besides music
you know what i'm saying right now but
just because i got so much with the
music coming on like
with the uh album and just running
around everywhere like trying to
you know just do everything for this
album so i ain't really just
get to so have you been neglecting the
restaurant the food truck [ __ ]
yeah like i really i sold my food truck
like at the cove and i ain't really even
open my restaurant back up for real i
just ain't have time to
just even mess with it for real like
that but
you know one of them things like i can
always do like i really
right right right right yeah you know
i'm saying really no no
yeah i think that that's like you know
you're one of the few artists that i met
that that's coming up that's like
i think really understands like you know
how to put your money in different
places and
and and to kind of be a little bit more
responsible than most when it comes to
you know not burning through your bread
like that
[Music]
let me let me ask you this because i
know you know you had experienced
the colombia [ __ ] and then [ __ ] with
empire and then the drake
record happens and then that goes over
to warner a little bit and yeah
i'm sure you know at any given time you
could have signed with
anybody what made you want to stay
independent
stay down with ghazia and the team of
empire uh
i just had more freedom like i had just
way more freedom like
you know i felt like i was you know just
running my own show you feel me and i
was just doing what i knew
worked it they was just funding whatever
i wanted to do you know what i'm saying
so i was like
i really had no reason to assign to a
major uh
because like they was you know i had i
had like videos with like other labels
and stuff like that
like major labels right you know what
i'm saying guys i know was able
was willing to you know saying talk to
them same numbers but stay
independent and i was getting most i was
like wow why would i you know what i'm
saying can you tell us who was like
number two you were considering
oh i think it was it was a it was a it
was horrible between like
a republican or republican uh
empire oh republican i mean that's true
i mean republicans like the superstar
label yeah yeah
for sure um was there ever any
discussions about you going over to ovo
at all or
uh yeah we had it was it was discussions
it was it was discussions
it was like a thing for for a minute
something you were seriously considering
yeah yeah yeah i was considering it
really i feel like it
it could have happened you know i'm
saying it was just like uh
you know when i just used when i used to
talk to drake about it he was just like
he he released the pressure he was like
man i love you know what i'm saying
love to have you over here he was just
like i just want you to uh
you know a lot of stuff and they start
opening up to you
you know what i'm saying and uh
you know basically just telling me he he
already know like
all the labels from the be coming at me
and stuff like that and to just
kind of like just wait you know me i was
fresh out there like i'm gonna decide oh
you know worse yeah you can get the
crazy advance the crazy bag
type type jump but i was able to uh
just do what was right for my career for
real like that
so so did drake like make an official
offer no
no no no they never did not i never
really after he said that i never really
like pressed on it for real
you know what i'm saying i never really
pressed on it so
it was like just a conversation or like
quick conversation
uh his team was just like uh you know
what i'm saying when you
you know saying uh let us know uh
before you sign uh your deal just like
kind of communicate with us and just
let us know so we can you know have a
chance to talk things over with yourself
it was kind of like just helpful like
just steering me
steering me uh through the whole process
right right
right without really just trying to make
me sad to them kind of give you some big
homie advice
yeah for sure yeah him and his team or
morgan i think morgan over there um
do you feel like you get enough credit
when it comes to kind of like kicking
off a lot of the [ __ ] that's hot right
now like i feel like you've been doing
this
this this singing and love [ __ ] for
before a lot of people yeah because
people look at you as a new artist but
you're
you're really not a new artist yeah
you've been putting in work for like the
last seven or eight years you know what
i'm saying
do you feel like you get the the flowers
you you deserve when it comes to kind of
doing a lot of this [ __ ] before
everybody else uh
no i don't feel like i get the you know
what i'm saying the
the the the fly was like
through like the the media and stuff
like that i feel like
it shows when you go out into the real
world you know what i'm saying you got
in the real world like
internet don't matter you know what i'm
saying when it comes to packing out a
club like
none of this stuff matters tick tock
don't matter right none of this stuff
matters uh it's about
and have you been through these trenches
before you know what i'm saying so
it kind of shows when i go out in person
towards
didn't you know saying on the internet
for real what about from your peers
because like i feel like obviously meek
tapped in early
uh drake is tapped like i think i think
a lot of people within the industry at
least who have been tapped in kind of
know if you know you know type
i mean even people like who just love
music who just done their research on me
i feel like that's why i've been able to
uh
do like collab with more people that
people probably just feel like it's too
early in my career to collab with
i feel like that's kind of why because
they
see why you know saying how far they
came and just
how far my roots go into music you know
what i'm saying
it make you want to work with me so i
feel like some of the people like that
may
work at like uh you know what i'm saying
the the companies and stuff like that
don't really know
but the people who tapped it in the
music industry they really they really
know
and you're i feel like you're also
tapping in with young artists like i
know
i saw you tapping with the homie from
tampa taliban duda
um what is it like first of all
we talked about this last time like you
come from the school of boozy so you are
if you're in a city i don't know anymore
but at a point in time
if you had your bag right yeah you could
pull up on blue and get you get
get you get your get your issue you know
what i'm saying
um but when it comes to like you know
like when we see you on other people's
records like
like like is it something that you have
to want to do at this point or are you
still like hey look if the price is
right
i'm on that thing uh yeah it's really
something i had to want to do for
like right now you know what i'm saying
and then but it's still
i still get the bag doing it but it's
like you know i'd have been offered to
build a lot of records
that i just passed on you know upset
just because
it probably just makes sense for me uh
you know not anything against the artist
or nothing like that it's just
it really makes sense what i have going
on then i really backed up on
stuff right now like i'm so backed up on
features and
it's stuff that i just don't wanna over
play i'm talking about features from
big artists you know what i'm saying
well you just had a feature come out
with was it with her
yeah yeah which is [ __ ] crazy
i saw that happen like on twitter right
yeah yeah
it's dope to see like the fruit will you
see that
that happen you reply yeah and then the
song comes out
yeah now for sure i feel like everybody
i ever hit up didn't hit me back like
everybody ever like
tweet everybody that i went after like
you know what i'm saying
didn't hit me back and just got with me
like i feel like that's why
everything just be natural like kind of
how did everything with her go down did
she just send you a record or was it
something where you guys
got in the studio so you guys actually
got in together yeah we made like four
workers
that's amazing that's very rare nowadays
yeah not for sure usually it's like yo
here's the mp3 there's an open thing
do what you do on it send it back yeah
i'd rather wait before do that because i
just be like you know what i'm saying
i'm more of a creator especially when
it's an artist like that
i like to get in and like feel feel
vibes and stuff like that so
so you guys got four records yeah i
don't think all of them coming out
though i just know we we
cut we cut four records uh she chose one
for her ad man i chose one for mine
so she's on the album that's big man
what was her process like and like
like because i feel like you're do you
do you
do the melody first then punch in the
lyrics or like like you know what i'm
saying
i i do i do i write the lyrics in the
mirror i mean i do the
lyrics in the middle at the same time i
just get on the mic and just
go so the paradise song uh it was just
more like i was already working on the
idea when she walked in the studio
filming and when she walked in i kind of
was like we're just gonna
just go to the next song like work on
something fresh but she was like oh i
liked i liked that finish that so i just
finished it and then we just got the
collab and working on it
um who is uh somebody who has tapped in
with you that we might not expect
because i feel like like musically
you're in a different pocket than a lot
of new and
upcoming artists so there might be some
some interesting people reaching out man
i'm sure you might even have a feature
on the way from from somebody we might
not expect
yeah even a lot of been a lot of artists
reaching that you know what i'm saying
there's been a lot of others that i
reached out to there's reaching back you
know i'm saying like uh
like i think i was just uh
[ __ ] and other dates just uh on
twitter
just right nicky i just like man you
know
i thought with you you know nicki minaj
yeah i was like uh
i fought with you cause i do [ __ ] with
him of course she's she's the girl yeah
yeah uh i was like i ain't just saying
that i ain't just saying that because we
should do a record even though we should
hi and then like a couple minutes later
like she had liked it and followed me on
ig
and uh she had hit me up the next day
was like uh
send me something so you know so you
guys have have had some dm's you and
nikki
uh did you it was like yeah we said did
you send her a record
uh i sent her some ideas uh
she said she gonna she said she gonna
get back with me so i don't really know
if it's gonna happen or not
uh but i don't know kind of just me
kind of just from the outside looking in
i feel like she gonna do it because i
don't even think she even wakes up time
right you know saying hitting back and
she won't go
yeah i don't feel like nicki i don't
feel like nicki's hitting everybody back
yeah
i feel like i know something else she
ain't gonna dm you and tell you to send
you something she don't [ __ ] with you
bro yeah
not for sure so i mean hopefully
hopefully that's the thing like either
way you know what i'm saying i'm messing
with the tough stuff
you know it's crazy you got such an ill
tone like i feel like
i want to hear you with like i feel like
i want to hear you on some like [ __ ]
with gideon or something like i feel
like you guys have
like like yeah a lot of things a lot of
things when you are already like uh
oh is that something that's happening i
mean it's just like it's just
just stay tuned i threw that out there
by the way i had no [ __ ] idea
you you consider yourself more of a r b
artist or a hip-hop artist i feel like
right now i'm more of a army artist
right now
i feel like i'm just the artist overall
but i still feel like right now i'm just
playing that pocket
it's like no tiller when i ever bounce
back though because i just you know
like i said i just do every type of
music however i feel
uh but right now i'm kind of riding that
pocket right now for the show
so i know you're in the bay you linked
with hit maker right
um he produced baddest uh chris brown's
on the hook which is
yeah in my opinion the most talented
artist alive
yeah yeah he can ball you up on the
basketball court
he can paint a mural on on your [ __ ]
wall
he can act he can sing and and i'm
pretty sure he can fight you know yeah
um but but how like like like give me
the process like how did how did chris
brown end up coming together on the song
uh that was something just he a play
hitman put together you know saying i
came in
the hook was already uh the hook was
they went already wrote they
uh dude ivory wrote the hook while we
was in the studio and then i did the
verses
and then uh berg sent it off
yeah he sent it off and brown got on it
but you know
after that you know saying we kind of
like
became cool like yeah how was the video
shoot i know you shot the videos
like last week right yeah it was cool it
was cool it was a little lit
cool guy in person uh yeah yeah i
supposed to be putting up on the night
so
you know saying we just keep keeping the
vibes going do some more records man
yeah like just you know i'll be already
like
press press the music i'd be like to
start with the you know what i'm saying
just the friendship the relationship i
know the music gonna be easy that's yeah
if you guys are cool yeah that's the
easiest
sometimes you're just talking about
ideas and just talking about you know
what i'm saying
uh yeah just the creative space in
general you feel me
i feel like the last time i saw you you
had to rush home
because you were having a newborn baby
is that right yeah
how's the baby oh he's good he good good
you're good
is the baby walking yet crawling nah he
he he trying to crawl he
like he want to cry but he ain't really
crying yet yeah that's the worst when
they start crawling and then you gotta
worry about them bumping their head on
the [ __ ] coffee table
rolling over out the bed and [ __ ] yeah
have has he rolled off the bed yet
yeah that [ __ ] was right you feel like
he's gonna die that's
happened to me with my baby he rode off
the bed i i [ __ ] i felt terrible yeah
yeah
i was like they gonna do that here baby
gonna bump the head now i know i
probably bumped my [ __ ]
have you um i feel like at a certain
point in time most young artists end up
moving to la i know you were in
mississippi kind of out the way
like have you gotten a spot out here
like you still kind of out the way
uh i'm still i'm still out the way i'm
in georgia now but uh
yeah i ain't got a spot out here uh yet
you're here a lot though
yeah i've been here a lot recently just
because i was working on my album though
yeah yeah so this is where i sat for
sure give me your
like r b top three who's your top three
rb artist all the time man
like yours not who you think everyone
else will like but like your personal
favorites uh
uh i feel like you know what i'm saying
justin
r kelly no i'm saying shout out to r
kelly we got hey can we get it can we
can we can we just
i just want to give our kelly flowers
yes he is not a good human being but he
[ __ ] is the greatest of all time
yeah nobody wants it in the verses
nobody
you know what i'm saying let me see
uh i wanna can i sit can i go sit on
michael michael michael jackson
uh another quite possibly
not great human being but great artist
you know what i mean
so far we're two for three on uh on
[Music]
michael jackson's probably more pop
though to be fair i feel like
you know i feel like who a lot of people
sleep on that i uh
really really enjoy is uh part of next
door
oh party's one of the best writers of
the last like 25 years
yeah no for sure for sure yeah now his
pen game is ridiculous what's your
favorite part
three though
what's your favorite r kelly album
double up
double up yeah wait double up yeah yeah
yeah yeah that jungle
i feel like i feel like the generic
answer is always 12 play
yeah i ain't i don't think i even never
heard you never heard 12 play
oh man what i just go through
that [ __ ] on right now i just know all
these songs but i don't i ain't i ain't
never just
really don't you ever listen to him
though i was born the double album r
yeah yes that's probably far as i go
back
yeah one man oh half on a baby
yeah damn that's crazy uh what's
something you've learned man in the last
like
seven or eight months ever like since
you've gotten the number one record like
something you've learned about yourself
or just maybe how to maneuver
differently like
what's because you you like i said
you're not like a new artist you've been
through a lot but like what's something
you've learned with the newfound fame
and the new level of success
uh i don't really feel like you know
what i'm saying i
i really feel like i don't know i really
feel like
you know this is exactly how you know
saying i thought thought it was gonna be
you know what i'm saying uh i feel like
i just i'm trying to move different
trying to go a little different with my
career
uh like i said like i'm trying to be
like a tour
artist like a hard ticket yeah yeah it's
hard to pass up those brown bags though
yeah you feel me but i mean that was
that's why my situation so good cause
like
i couldn't at first because i was with a
major label not making a lot of money
on music yeah i would imply so i make a
lot of money off
just music you feel me so i don't really
have to do that you know what i'm saying
so i can focus on you know saying adam's
focus on i feel like that's why i got uh
you know just in a good in a good place
where i could just
do other stuff and put my energy towards
other stuff
hey interrupting the interview to tell
you about our good friends at odd socks
now as you can see
i always have my odd socks on baby you
know what i'm saying
oh shout out to my bony ass knees um
listen go to oddssocksofficial.com they
got all the craziest socks
these are the outsiders you know what
i'm saying they got spongebob
they got cheech and chong listen
breaking bad
godfather whatever you need they got it
and now they have underwear that's right
you can get your odd socks underwear
the boxer briefs are the best underwear
that you could ever fit on your ass
trust me when i tell you
these are chucky draws what you know
about top ramen underwear all right
go to oddssocksofficial.com use the
keyword bootleg kev at checkout
and you'll save 20 off of of your order
underwear masks slippers socks
whatever you need they got it
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
heaven check out save twenty percent
is busy still involved uh like what
with you with your situation yeah yeah
yeah he's still involved he's still
involved
he's still eating yeah still getting his
piece yeah yeah i said i got three more
i got three more projects like you know
what i'm saying
if they were boosting like people just
keep like just missing i'm just so be
so tired of just explaining it but i
have
uh like uh
just stated once before that you know
the situation is a custom situation like
i think you might have stated that here
before yeah like yeah
for real though it's like it's not like
people when people say
you could still honor something and not
be
because okay if i sit here and say that
the contract
negotiator he said
i'm gonna i was gonna sign a deal with
empire i was going to go get
you know saying a bigger bag like that
and i said
okay we had three more albums
left in the contract you know what i'm
saying so
he still get those three albums you know
what i'm saying he still get those three
hours
like i said you still make money you
feel me i saw you just post like a
compilation of funny boozy moments
yeah like boosie's like the funniest
[ __ ] like quite possibly in
hip-hop history
yeah what is like the funniest [ __ ]
you've ever like witnessed in person
with busy
cause i mean it's just i've been around
him and like
i just feel like i feel like i know he
tried to do the reality tv show thing
and i thought it should have been a lot
bigger
yeah but like he is probably the most
entertaining person yeah now
he only really have no favorite favorite
moment like you know what i'm saying
boost is just funny and
like people like booster really like you
know what i'm saying a real
brother i just hate when people be like
just taking my words and we
like for real though people know so much
less people
know so little about deals and stuff
like that that i just
the easiest thing for me to say is yeah
i'm still signing a booster you feel me
of course because if i break it now
for real you people people normal
person's not even going to understand
what i'm even saying you're feeling they
just gonna be like oh he's trying to say
he ain't signing a boost yeah
i'm still sounding booster like i said
he's always better however
when you when you find out he got shot
man because that was rough man
yeah i talked to him right after that so
i knew he was good like before the world
you know saying
like i said i'm close to boosters so
when you see [ __ ] like that happen
because we've seen a lot of people get
hit like recently you know benny the
butcher
and you know a lot of people have you
know fortunately
i feel like you know jim jones said this
recently that being an artist is one of
the most dangerous jobs in the world
does that kind of you know i feel like
you
you have to kind of take notes and like
move differently right yeah
i feel like i'm more like i ain't really
never thought i'd have to be
you know saying roller like i'm rolling
but you know it just come with it man
cause
some people just don't you know some
people don't
think logical you feel me they just
especially when they see your artist
it's like a
a button just click you just you know
what i'm saying
so you just got to be protected man yeah
they can't watch it you can't watch
everything
all the time if you think about like pop
smoke like he wouldn't even know it was
like a kid you saw where he was at on
instagram so kids from the hood and they
rolled up on them and like
that could happen to anybody yeah i'm
sure you know that it came with my
and it came with my airbnb before it
came up you know whatever while you were
there
recently nope i want that though so just
i had just left like i had just left
that morning and i just had level
randomly too i was just like i had just
got up because i posted like two more
days
but uh i had just lived
when i got up in the morning i was like
i'm gonna go home be with my kids before
i
go to africa i just wanted to see my
kids i had to got out that morning just
booked the flight and dipped
and uh i had booked the flight of dip
and
uh so you left and then right after you
left some people ran up in the airbnb
you were at
yeah was anybody there yeah uh my
manager and my artist was there
did they get robbed or what yeah yeah
yeah oh wow they're they're good though
yeah they're great they're great that's
great like that's crazy because you
never know how they could have found out
you were there
yeah they could you know what else too
we was just we was hot born i ain't
gonna lie we was hot boy we was there
for like
weeks you know saying doing the la
experience having house parties
[ __ ] like that just just just
maybe not moving the smartest yeah not
moving the spot but you know we had
secured and stuff over there but they
came in like two of them but it don't
matter yeah it don't matter
yeah yeah that's crazy so so obviously
you learn from that
yeah because i feel like it could have
been bad man yeah like i feel like if
if i would yell like you know said
knowing me
i probably it probably i wouldn't even
say like i'm just rambling now but i
didn't i don't know like
how i sleep you fear me it probably
would have been a shootout but you never
know like who would have worn that [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying because i sleep
like that was out here yeah yeah
so yeah you know what's crazy too with
these airbnbs is like
everybody using the same the same ones
so all you got to see is one little
sliver on someone's story yeah
and if you know you know where that one
is because every rapper
every artist there's only a certain
amount of airbnbs in the hills
and like yeah baby [ __ ] that's that's
crazy
thank god you want to saw your kids you
know what i'm saying yeah talk about
your trip to africa i saw you went out
there
um with ghazi and nima and uh it looked
crazy man i mean it look i heard
i did you go with them nema told me the
story about
how they went to the nigerian prince's
house or like
okay yeah he told me like yo we had to
bow and like kiss the floor and [ __ ]
i didn't go with them dude but how was
your trip to africa man oh it was good
it was good
was there a first time huh yeah that was
my first time
period how would you describe it because
like you know we always hear about going
to africa and
they look beautiful yeah now it's it's
different
like i said it's uh you know they got
they you know saying they
bad spots but they got some spots that
look you know just like
america you know what i'm saying uh
because nigeria like a big city you know
they got like 220 million people so
uh it was good it was a good experience
it was a way different experience than
being
uh in america of course
and uh they gonna run them pockets when
you get over there though
right right right right they're gonna
run their pocket they get they know
you're a tool they know so they make
sure
you tip in or they yeah they you got
to do everything like you know what i'm
saying going through the airport going
right
right
i really don't even know if i would have
made it over there without like just
knowing people there
right like no i don't give a damn yeah
not just i'm just saying like just
to you got to have like you got to know
somebody who's up in there yeah
like did you out there just to to go out
there to do i know you shot a video
there right yeah
yeah i shot a video with devito and i
was just going to mess with like you
know what i'm saying pulling up on the
you know
i heard that they out there they call
him david o though all right but in the
u.s we call them david they treat davido
like a king
oh he's that guy yeah yeah there's uh
what's the other guy's name uh i'm
interviewing uh
fireboy tomorrow they start uh
they stuck when they see devito they
start clapping like
do they know who you are in africa yeah
they knew what i was yeah
they knew they knew it was it was crazy
like you know i'm saying
i ain't even know they was gonna really
know me like that but like it was it was
is that the first time you've been out
of the u.s and saw like you have fans
all over the world uh if if i'm not
counting the bahamas because i've been
to that was the only other place out the
country i went
and that everybody knew me you know
saying so the bahamas in
africa yeah bahamas survived yeah
yeah yeah mohammed's in africa but i
ain't never been overwhelmed so they
probably not know
i got a lot of friends from london and i
got a lot of fans in europe and the uk
and stuff like that that was all pretty
oh yeah now that because
[ __ ] is over you should be you should be
able to get around a little bit more
like i said i'm just trying to tour like
two times a year and do a
you know one international tour would
you would you be down like i'm sure
how the people have been hitting you to
probably open up some of these bigger
tours coming has that
have those conversations happen uh yeah
but i just wanted to do my own tour
because i was like
you know saying i'm just ready to build
my i'm just ready to build my own uh
my own hard ticket history you know what
i'm saying yeah i got to show you that's
how you build up those hardcore fans
yeah you feel me yeah i i wanna i'm
gonna i wanna go ahead and do that
right now that's that's i think that's
the wave yeah then like maybe next year
or something you'll maybe go do like the
chris brown or drake tour
yeah any other records with uh
anybody else on the album you could talk
about oh
i got uh i got
a record with john legend wait wait wait
wait wait wait you got a record with
john legend
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
it's actually my intro guy you got john
legend on the intro
yeah wait a minute
how the [ __ ] did that happen is this
who reached out to who uh i reached out
i reached out to his team and uh
he they just did they just did yeah did
he hit you in your pockets for it or did
he do it
uh i don't really know because i don't
handle that
you're gonna find out when you see the
statement yeah we gotta recoup for it
you probably did
but i think you know another thing like
that i don't really think it's about the
money it's like easy
you got john legend on the intro to your
album yeah did you talk to him like
like meet him i ain't never even talking
i know you talk to him like that
i ain't never even talked to him like
wow
all right continue who else
we've established hers on the album uh
big show
big sean's on the album um
um obviously chris brown the two chains
yeah chris brown
uh obviously drake uh
givion no no okay no no i'm just i'm
trying i'm fishing you see i'm floyd
bailey
wally okay uh-huh uh devito
yeah that pretty i think that's pretty
much it uh i'm working on i'm working on
this
what's the name of the album yeah is
that out here uh no i
i ain't dropping a problem about time
and when is interview dropping what are
you gonna tell uh
probably next week like uh i ain't
enough
i wanna lost it with them i wanna know
your name with the aldo all right all
right well i
i i will say i've been hitting it i've
been hitting at it
for a long time like just within my
statuses of post and stuff
i just been hitting that hint it's gonna
be like investments part
whatever the [ __ ] that's over yeah that
came to a conclusion yeah that came to
conclude
yeah that's crazy man well look uh it's
good to see you winning bro
anytime anybody ever asked me about you
or you know brian sampson's like hey i'm
working
like yo blue's one of the smartest
nicest kids i've met in the game
man for sure you already know i messed
with you and you're a grown ass man too
you
raising your family the right way you
know you you know you're handling your
business the way you should bro
and you know i think i think uh
i i commend you for staying independent
too man yeah but so
i gotta you know i'm just trying to pay
by pay pay by the way you know what i'm
saying just show people like
you know don't believe that narrative
that they try to paint that you can't be
this debt without them you know without
the machine without the machine you feel
me because
we is the machine you feel me so the
artist is the machine
be clear y'all have the leverage bro
like that's what i try to tell people
like
you can take that advance all you want
you got to pay it back
yeah and at what rate yeah you know what
i mean
i i feel like i feel like just the game
changing i feel like i'm at the
forefront of just showing people
i feel like me my situation i made so
many people see the independent side as
as like the thing to do you know what
i'm saying just because
how i've been like maneuvering
actually come in handy like being
independent come in handy because a lot
of big artists
you know saying that we want to deal
with other big labels you know what i'm
saying uh if they already will you know
what i'm saying with a label
right so being independent is like you
can work with who you want yeah like
it's like it's it's less easy for them
like they can just
you know what i'm saying i was gonna say
you said something earlier that was
important
that we kind of glossed over and that
was that you're not having to go and
grab all the bags that you used to have
to grab at the
you know whatever city where you pull up
and do the club and [ __ ] but
at the time you're speaking from a
perspective of somebody who's
really been through most situations in
music because
you had a major type situation with
colombia right
and like you were saying you weren't
seeing money off off of the music
right you had pla and this is something
this is somebody who's has
plaques yeah you have plaques you know i
had like
multiple like gold songs that's what i'm
saying and and so for people who don't
understand like
most artists that you see that sign to
these majors and i ain't need to get
nothing but a damn 150 000
advance yeah and how did you not recoup
that right that's crazy
off of off of how many gold records two
but that's insane just within that
two or two years because i don't think i
don't think people understand like
when you get that you sign that record
deal you're gonna get that check right
but like from you better make that last
or you better start to build your merch
and your touring and all this [ __ ]
because
it's going to be a while before you see
money from your actual music
that's why a lot of people just be
wondering like i'm like you know what's
in like how he
doing he's like hey you know what i'm
saying get this house i
get this call like you know what so he
just got nick just got in the game and
all this i'm just like bruh
like it's it's just different you feel
me a lot of people
most of the people that i know regular
major record deals like
wanting to get out you know what i'm
saying they hate it yeah they hate it
they're unhappy so
uh i just i just feel like it's just a
different like even
even with the major labels thing i ain't
even you know i'm not [ __ ] on that
situation it's just how people structure
they did because you could have an
independent type situation
with a major you know people don't
people don't know that it's just it's
all about leverage and lawyers and
if you're smart yeah you feel me and
you're not thirsty to get to like
because a lot of people see that front
end check
and they're like yeah i ain't a lot like
them
a million dollars don't need people but
what your terms look like yeah only i
don't even get excited when i see deals
like
two million dollars no more and stuff
like that yeah i mean you went through
it like you said you took 150 thousand
dollar advance you had two gold records
and you're getting 35
checks yeah that's crazy
so that is crazy but that that happens
to a lot of people man
but you were smart enough to take your
money put it into investments and
you still got the tour bus that you
right now yeah yeah yeah i'm using it on
my tour
i'm using it i ain't even been written
that i don't think i never even really
like
i just used to just i just used to be
like
i'm gonna rent it out i'm gonna win it
but it just it just
be sid there so you tap into any real
estate or anything like that i mean i
just ain't had time to right now you
know
working on music like uh i'm probably
trying to get like
i'm gonna build a new piece to my house
uh
like another i'm gonna spend like
another like 1.2 to build me
like a entertainment section of my house
like oh you're just gonna never have to
leave home
yeah you feeling but i still leave so
sad though but that's gonna probably be
my
first investment of property
if i decide to move i'm really trying to
build uh to get the person that built
that
to build me like uh like over the next
five years to build me like because i
feel like
everybody loved that it's going to be so
easy to sell because when i posted my
house
all the raffles was in my dm like man
so i feel like if i take the same like
full plan idea
and just build like two three four of
them houses you know what i'm saying
i can sell them easily what made you
want to um like
like get out of your hometown like get
out of alabama because you know alabama
i i do feel like
we've we've noticed like a lot of people
like when they stay home
usually that's where the most hate is
you know uh i just wanted to you know
what i'm saying i just wanted to
see more you know see more you feel me
uh
you know thing i beat her uh sometimes
uh but i just wanted to you know
you know somewhere like 20 22 years well
also it's not like you're from miami
like
i'm assuming alabama's not the most
[ __ ] lit place yeah it's not
it's it's not it's like i think i want
to you know a lot of things that my
family you know saying wanted to do
is we don't really have you know what in
like in i stay like by atlanta so
anything i could think of atlanta gonna
have
right there take them to the zoo the
aquarium six flags
disneyland but i mean not there's that's
what i said just
like that's the floor they're a new
disneyland and then like a music
stuff like that anything i want to take
them to uh i could i could just do it
like that because
it's just right there you feel me yeah
everything's right there you you're like
a
two-hour flight to orlando to go to
disney world yeah worst-case scenario
yeah a lot of times i just like i really
just use my butts for like my family
trips and stuff like i just get all my
siblings
just get on the bus and just go like to
disneyland or something what are you
doing like
i feel like you're built for longevity
in this game with the way you think and
[ __ ] but is that something you
consciously think of like how
how can i be here in 10 years yeah as
opposed to like
i do that i do that i feel like uh you
know just putting together that's why i
just put together like this
masterpiece project because i feel like
once this project dropped people just
gonna
realize like how how talented i am and
like i said i
write uh and
i feel like i'm just gotta you know say
a generation of sound cause i could do
everything everybody whoever encountered
me every time i got on the phone with
labels they always say like
you know saying you're a generational
artist that's people just been
saying that ever since i you know i'm
saying uh
they discovered me so i feel like i'm
gonna have you know it's
a lot of longevity in the game just
because uh
i'm just crazy i'm just crazy with the
pen or
you know everybody feel like that you
know you're gonna start writing for the
artist
uh i've been i've been writing for the
article i've been writing for the artist
like i get in the studio and just check
their credentials
everyone yeah that was so like anything
anything you can talk about
yeah um i just like
i can but i just don't really be wanting
to because i
feel like some are you know something it
scares some artists you know what i'm
saying
all right just you know saying talking
about it and stuff like that and
me always but i always believed in like
collaborative like i've never been on
ain't nobody right for me
like yeah if you're in the studio with
someone in there and they give you a
like of course
you're not gonna use it
like i said i always do my own verses
and stuff like that but like for
like hooks and just ideas and stuff like
that uh you're open to collaborating
yeah i'm hoping to collaborate like i
said the
chris brown song like i ain't right none
of that like that idea was
already i already know but i swagged on
my verse you feel me and this is
you know it's a good song he's going
crazy yeah he's killing in the radio
right now you guys had a first
a nice first couple weeks of radio for
sure independently
yeah for sure that's what i was like i
was like man y'all damn y'all doing good
we got two we got two burgers on the
radio man
yeah yeah both of them hey that your
mind still will not die
yeah that that's what i said what i'm
telling you before when i made that
record
but i was going to get ready to put out
another another record you know i was
just telling my team i was just like man
i just want a record that's just gonna
survive bruh like i just want to work
with it right
i want to talk about something that
people are going to feel
forever and it sounds like nothing else
on the radio right now yeah you feel me
so it's like a whole different vibe
yeah so i knew it was gonna stick once
it i knew it was gonna stick like one
time once i made i just knew it was
gonna stick because all my records
before
was always records that like stuck like
in the streets like
in the hearts of like the fans in the
underground world you know what i'm
saying so i know
i could do that on the main screen level
you feel me so
you know who i think everybody would
love to hear you work with would be
someone like rod wave is that somebody
you would ever
oh i know rod wave seems to be like a
very emotional guy
you know what i'm saying a little
erratic on twitter at times but i feel
like
i feel like fans would love to see y'all
do some [ __ ]
yeah i feel like oh we i mean we used to
chop it up like you know
since he you know said blow though he
really chopped it up like that but like
you know bro used to be like you know
saying a real fan of mine like before he
even blow
blowed up like you could definitely hear
it for sure nah for sure like he used to
be
like a real fan of mine so uh maybe one
day
yeah you know you know you know how it
is man you know really
but if you go back to his uh like he's
like his first video with the
heart on ice like that was when i i
first like met him at this show
uh he was over enough for me uh and uh
his cameraman was trying to get a little
drop for he was doing like a little
promo video and he was like man blue do
a drop for my artist
then i know you notice how i got on the
camera like you know i've messed with
them better
live bro hard so stuff like that so you
know it's just good to see you know what
it's just good to see like
artists just blow up i saw so many
artists blow up through
you know what i'm saying i just saw some
of the artists blow up like artists that
i was
messing with tapping it earlier tapping
in early with it or
just blowing up you know saying some of
them stay silent some of them like you
know what i'm saying get on they
you know it's like i ain't never did
nothing bro you know what i'm saying but
yeah sometimes if it'll be like
sometimes there'll be other people in
there like right oh y'all you know
saying
y'all sound saying you should you know
saying some people be feeling like
you know you know if y'all in the same
lane they really don't want to like work
you know
yeah i think that that's the thing that
i would love to see like
like like you know like you said like
unfortunately like i remember when
he went online and said what he said
about other people singing and [ __ ] but
it's like yo just because
you you do this and we kind of are in
the same lane
they don't make us competition or you
know that's that weirdo [ __ ] i feel like
that should be happening a lot with
artists and it's like bro like
especially if it's people out the same
city you know what i'm saying obviously
he's from saint pete but like
yeah you would just like think like why
not share each other's fans why not you
know collaborate you know what i'm
saying yeah he'll be good like i like
i like natural stuff though i like of
course i like natural stuff like you
know what i'm saying i never know what's
going to happen in the
in the future but you know i just like
want to work with everybody that want to
work with me you know saying 100 man you
know what's happening
well the album is coming soon crazy
features uh the song is on the radio go
go request that [ __ ] and uh and check
out the homie young blue man just get it
boom